طبقا لويل جورنال في القمه المقترحه تحظى
بدعم قوي من القاده الاوروبيين بمن فيهم
الرئيس الفرنسي مسؤولون اوروبيون قالوا
انهم يعملون مع كييف لاعاده صياغه خطه
السلام الاوكرانيه بطرق تجعلها اكثر قبولا
للقوى العالميه كبير موظفي الرئاسه
الاوكرانيه اندرير ماك قال ان المفاوضات
المباشره مع روسيا ليست ممكنه طالما بقيت
قواتها في اوكرانيا الرئيس الاوكراني
خطه من عشر نقاط وناقشها مع نظيره
الاميركي جو بايدن من النقاط المطروحه
استعاده سيطره اوكرانيا على اراضيها هو
اعاده الاسرى ومحاكمه جرائم الحرب اضافه
لضمان الامن الغذائي من خلال حمايه صادرات
الحبوب الاوكرانيه
التوقعات تشير الى ان القمه ربما تعقد قبل
الاجتماع المزمع لقاده دول الناتو في
يوليو المقبل في ليتوانيا بحسب جورنال
فكره القمه تبلور ت خلال محادثه بين
الرئيسين الاوكراني والفرنسي في فبراير مع
ضغط الاخير على كييف لقبول فكره انه لا بد
من محادثات سلام مع الكرملين بنهايه
المطاف لمتابعه المزيد من الاخبار
والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه والوثائقيات
والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا الاشتراك في
قناتنا على اليوتيوب الضغط على زر الاعجاب
وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات